hello we're in the studio at night out
of uniform
hair's a mess what's going on well guys
frankly i got the second job yes sir
i am now part of the vaxxed team i got
5g
installed and let me tell you signals
better than ever okay honestly i got it
all installed right here and i'm excited
about it
but frankly the reason i didn't record
earlier in the day was because i wasn't
feeling great look second dose
you're gonna feel a little i don't feel
so good it hits you
honestly if you're worried it's not that
bad i was kind of feeling a little bit
bad and then i
took a tylenol and then we're doing all
right okay so i baby myself all day
but uh you know according to some people
i might be dead in a few days
you guys never understood you never
understood the first thing about this
i mean you guys know big daddy alex
jones he's never been wrong before
everyone knows how big of a fan i am of
alex jones so i'm not saying that
insultingly but let's see who's right
here
basically anyone taking these vaccines
they're all designed to the same thing
um is going to have neurological
disorders within one year
most of the people taking the vaccine
will be dead within 10 and this john
hopkins says it all right here
now you guys know why i'm so eager to
get these videos out i don't have long
voice
so i wanted to talk to you guys dude
what the heck's up with my hair right
now i'm just gonna put it down
so i'm just wow dude i look like uh the
kid from uh
spider-man the the toby mcguire dude
from the greatest spider-man movie ever
here we go boys what do i how do i pull
it off
yes dude
[Music]
yeah baby uh anyway we're dealing with
it guys look i'm covid
i got a coping vaccine okay sympathize
with me i'm having a rough time here
tough time of it now speaking of actors
guys today
i'm making this video because a beverly
hills man was arrested for a ponzi
scheme
they got a quarter of a billion dollars
from people and he's like a f-less
celebrity called
zack avery you guys hear about this
actor arrested for running
film investment ponzi's game boys i i
don't know like do you
did these people watch coffeezilla i'm
gonna guess no so how did he do it how
did he pull it off it's kind of amazing
so apparently he solicit investors
saying he would purchase the regional
distribution
of rights to films and then license the
rights to platforms like netflix and hbo
now this is interesting specific scams
like this they kind of have to be a
little specific
you kind of it has to be like some weird
niche where people are like i would have
never thought of that
and then they'll go invest in your
stupid thing but guys and he's facing 20
years by the way
for this he ran something called one in
mm capital
but uh two things number one you can
never trust actors
let me tell you guys that right now if
somebody's pretending to be someone else
for a living do you know that person
ever probably not they ask you how you
are you just have to say that you're
fine when you're not really fine
but number two he wasn't even a good
actor his imdb
page has like a few movies apparently
the biggest movies he was in was
probably like fury
never heard of these movies i mean you
guys fell for this
idiot cause you're not watching
coffeezilla you're not watching spencer
cornelia you could have spotted this guy
a mile away i feel like
i'm the man of the house now this is the
real zack avery by the way and here's
the crazy thing dude now he has a
million views on this video
but only 9 000 likes which means it's
almost for sure that he boosted this
video
to get to where it is uh like with ads
and stuff so he ran ads
on his own show deal to give you an idea
of this man's mentality
you know why cause you're just a [ __ ]
child
your son was my best friend bro just
imagine replace this with like
i need you to invest 227 million dollars
with me
it's a get rich i mean um sorry it's a
for sure scheme
i mean it's a for sure it's a business
op
it's a business safe save money just
replace that with what he just said he's
saying right here would you believe him
would you buy in
do you think he's a good enough actor
would you fall for this he was my
brother
and he was one hell of a soldier come on
dude
everything he did work
it's in the eyes can't you tell that
dude bad actors they don't have the
they just like sold his eyes it was my
brother
you don't have the heart baby which is
why you probably ran a good ponzi scheme
allegedly allegedly though this guy made
two checks he may not have lived long
but the life he did live
it was full and it was lived as
completely as anyone i've ever met
and i am honored that i was able to be a
part of it
i am completely bro it's the same eyes
no matter what cd is
it's the same like i am completely in
love with you daniela
come on dude we don't believe you but
apparently
people did for this netflix scheme this
whole licensing scheme he said it was
safe money
he said it's a safe investment because
we receive confirmation from our outputs
indicating the desire to acquire rights
and just imagine him saying that with
his 10 000 yard stare we receive
confirmation from each of our outputs
indicating the desire to acquire the
rights to any title
we provide bro stop
okay please stop look i'm hurting from
the covered vaccine and you're giving me
a headache okay
enough of that honestly i don't know
what i'm doing i just released the
healing touch video i should just
done done dude i feel better already
guys that's basically it i just wanted
to talk to you
i couldn't go a day without giving y'all
a video hope you get the you know 5g
shot in your arm and if you do get the
double dose you got to get the double
dose because it'll
you know doesn't work otherwise you
don't get as good as cell reception
that's basically it though
thanks for watching and and i'll see you
guys
that was where you tomorrow me wake up
and smell the coffee